and their friends and Nazis and we'll
have to get rid of them and the Israelis
are doing a very good job in the
beginning of that but everyone's going
to have to join in we cannot live with
these people we can't not because we
don't want to but because they cannot
live with us I think we have to start
saying very clearly if you don't like it
here go as you see these calls for
genocide on the Streets of London that's
specifically what he's talking about
there it's like at what point does the
Western defense of free speech come
right up against a group of people who
are here some of them legally but plenty
of them illegally who are gladly using
our freedoms against us and what do we
do in Liberal societies to make sure
that over time all of the good things
about liberalism how long can that work
when a whole bunch of people are here
gladly and proudly screaming that
they're here to tear it all down